all you have is the moment
I am in complete and total control over
my seconds and now I can be as happy as
I choose to be
my guest today is the incomparable Chef
puppets but that is a vegan Chef she is
the owner of the plant-based restaurant
stuff I eat in Los Angeles and she's
basically just an Unstoppable force of
nature I just love movement I love
knowing that I can move Chef Babette has
been featured on a ton of TV shows like
inside edition The Chew The Steve Harvey
Show and she's the author of the dessert
cookbook cash in on cashews she also
Chronicles her daily fitness journey on
social media which is really fun and
inspiring but perhaps the most
impressive thing about Chef Babette is
that she didn't actually even get
started with a healthy vegan diet or
even exercise for that matter until she
was in her 40s and she didn't start her
restaurant until her 50s each and every
one of us has to determine what is
important to me about the gift of life
and now at 72 years young she's crazy
fit like ripped and just radiant her
skin is insane full of amazing vitality
and life force and truly this Living
testament to the idea that it really is
never too late I started with with one
push-up
and every day
I would add a push-up start with one but
that brings the heat today she delivers
the goods with more energy and
enthusiasm than I've seen across this
desk in quite a while and she was such a
joy to spend time with but I'm not going
to make you wait any longer this is me
and your new inspirational role model
yeah
are you ready because we got a lot to
talk about I'm so ready oh so nice to
have you here what a delight to have you
in the studio so excited to get into it
with you I mean first of all you look
fantastic you came in your energy is
like through the roof your skin is
radiating your outfit is like off the
chain like everything about you is
positivity and like love and welcoming
this welcoming energy and you know I
mean just when I walked in here you guys
were already here and I was like wow
this is like
feel it thank you yeah thank you thank
you for having me yeah
um let's uh I don't even know where to
start because there's so many things I
want to do at the beginning but let's
start at the beginning why not yeah tell
me about growing up your relationship
with food with Fitness
the whole Evolution I want to hear every
beat of the story oh
my pleasure
I love to share
my life has been quite a journey but you
know that's that's what it is when we
come to this planet we're on a journey
and um
as a child
I went through quite a bit I um
was molested at five years old by a
total stranger
[Music]
um and I know I was five years old
because uh my sister
was in the crib in the next room
and I'm five years older than her wow is
that is that a memory that stayed with
you that you retrieved later never left
I never told anybody it was actually
the babysitter's son now I don't know if
this guy was an adult
but I was five so
he came up to my bedroom
did whatever he had to do and then he
left we both went downstairs where his
mother was doing laundry I stood on one
side of her he stood on the other side
of her nobody ever said a word and I
never told anyone until I was adult an
adult what was the inflection point that
caused you to finally talk to somebody
it was
a conversation
that I was having with my mother but
prior to that
um
you know I had had been with different
caretakers because my mother came from
North Carolina
she had a third grade education
but she was bound and determined not to
be on welfare
she did domestic work she cleaned she
cooked
and um she worked two and three jobs so
obviously we needed caretakers
um my brother was 10 years older than
myself and he was a kid that was always
in trouble juvenile hall so he wasn't
necessarily in my life it was myself and
my younger sister
I had a godparent that had actually
christened me
and my mother felt very comfortable
leaving me with her she was The
Seventh-Day Adventist right exactly but
she was cruel
it's very very cruel there was a time
that um
she told me I had to make a palette wash
all the dishes he had guests that
evening she said I want you to wash all
the dishes and then I want you to make
yourself a palette and go sleep in the
garage with the dog
as I was attempting to get the palate
together her husband said to me what are
you doing
and I said well godmother wanted me to
clean up the kitchen and then make a
palette now I'm only around
seven eight years old then
she wants me to go sleep in the garage
with booger bear that was the dog and he
said
go to bed
I'll clean the kitchen and don't ever
ever
make a palette to go sleep in the garage
with the dog now I never heard anymore
about it
but I'm sure he had something to say to
her so I went through that all week
and then my stepfather who was Italian
my mother had a a loving heart very open
so
race was never anything that we dealt
with everybody was the same and that was
the one great thing in in my life but
he would come to pick me up
and he would sit me in his lap
and pretend I was driving
the way home as he
fondled me or whatever so I had to live
with her during the week and go through
all of the pain of being mistreated with
her and then he would pick me up on
Fridays and then I had to go through all
that and that was after the baby that
was after the babysitter yeah because
now I'm three four years older
um
yeah it was pretty pretty nuts now you
know I think about my mom
determined not to get us on welfare we
weren't going to be a part of the system
no I'm not doing that I'm going to work
but what if we did receive welfare
would I have been able to be there with
her
would she have been able to watch me
more as we make our comments and our
judgments
towards people who receive assistance
sometimes it's needed but she did what
she felt was best so
the reason I wound up telling her I was
late in my 20s when I finally told her
about her husband
and the babysitter
she was making a comment uh a negative
comment about my first husband who was a
childhood sweetheart
and I said to her which I know it was
extremely painful at the time I said
well perhaps he doesn't come home and
endorse his checks and sign him over to
me
but there were some things your husband
did that my husband would never do and
they were done to me and she was like
what are you talking about
and I told her
and she said I saw him
Pat you one time
I told him
that if I was not enough for him he
should leave it stopped so obviously she
did say something to him I never knew
why it stopped but it stopped but when
those types of things happen to you as a
young person in your formative years
I suspect that makes it very difficult
to trust other people or to you know
embrace the you know the idea that the
world is a safe place like the world is
dangerous your mom doing what she
thought was in your best interest
entrusted you to certain people who
betrayed you profoundly
and you carrying that around for so many
years as a young person
how do you you know grapple with that
and
come out like with the the sort of
attitude that you have now
that is such an awesome question and I
was giving that a lot of thought last
evening
because
the pain
didn't stop there
when I got married at 21 and had a child
my spouse was addicted to heroin
so you can imagine what kind of life
that was I decided not to go to college
I went and got a job immediately out of
high school
and we were married for quite a number
of years
and then I met someone else
we divorced
and
he was abusive physically
so I've been cold cocked
I've been picked up and body slammed
I've had my head run through a wall
part of the journey
but it doesn't end there so when I'm
done with him
I meet someone else
this particular person
had me smoking crack cocaine
part of the journey yeah how old were
you then I'm now in my 30s
you know
um
but the crack cocaine was um
so debilitating
um
and what we did was she and I I was
working for the airlines when I started
using the crack the guy that kind of
used to whip me around he was a drug
dealer
um
and then after I left him and I was
living in Denver Colorado after I met
met him left him and moved back to Los
Angeles
and um met my brand new person
we decided we were going to cook crack
cocaine form the rocks and sell them
and that's how we would make our living
well he liked to snort it
and I like to smoke it
so you can imagine where that lifestyle
it was the chaos it was a higher mess
and um I can remember being at my
mother's home in the bedroom where I
grew up now we grew up on the east side
of L.A Washington Boulevard and Central
Avenue went to Thomas Jefferson High
School 20th Street Elementary School
Carver junior high school so I was a
East Side girl right
I can remember sitting in this bedroom
after smoking
these rocks
and going through a piggy bank
and I can remember it was like a voice
Sid so that's who you are now
the piggy bank that you had as a kid
piggy bank yeah
that was the very last time
I ever dealt with cocaine yeah I mean
it's not not that different than you
know sort of crawling through the carpet
looking for the tiny rocks that my baby
I smoke so much cornbread
yeah child look but did you were you
able to just stop or you say you have
this Epiphany stopped yeah when that
voice came to me I never went to
anything I stopped when got a job with
Republic Airlines and reservations and I
can remember the very second paycheck I
can remember driving on the 110 freeway
and saying to myself man
got this paycheck you could really get
high today and the other voice said and
mess everything up I have never looked
back
never looked back when it comes to this
powerful that is not that many people I
mean that's that's a tough one for most
people and to do it kind of on your own
is very unusual I did it yeah and I'm so
proud of myself that I did it but I I
I'm just now sharing this story
um
because I've walked in so many different
shoes rich I
I know that there's somebody out there
that can identify with what I'm saying
right now that knows exactly what I've
been sure you know what I mean I have to
share it's part of the journey it's part
of the experience and what I've done
because I I I embrace the love I met my
current husband
he turned me on
to the vegan lifestyle he wasn't even
vegan so now I'm reaching that point
where healing is about to begin
and I read two books Fit for Life by
Harvey and Marilyn diamond
and the mucusless diet healing system by
Professor Arnold Eric
changed my world let's put a pin in that
for a moment though because you just
turbocharged through a whole bunch of
stuff that I don't want to bypass too
quickly okay I'm I'm curious about how
you you made peace with the tumult of of
your childhood how you you know kind of
um work through the pain of those
abusive situations that you were in
embracing love
it was either be angry
judgmental
all of those things those those things
are not going to heal me
to take responsibility for being the
human that I am
and knowing that going forward each and
every second of my journey
I'm learning every single day I'm not
running a hundred obviously but I learn
every single day love is a lot easier
than hating
now I have said and I just learned this
a few weeks ago I've said I don't regret
not one step of my journey and I had
someone say to me
you should regret it those were horrible
things that happened to you
what's important is that you didn't
wallow in it
that's what's important right and and
regret is usually associated with
something that you did and these are
things that happened to you exactly
exactly but but now I can I feel it that
way I I regret that man came up to my
room and did that to me but I I didn't
stay there I embraced love and that is
where I am now it makes me want to cry
it's like I could be a bitter old cranky
lady
but I realize I have each and every
second guaranteed to me and I am now in
control of those moments and if there's
anybody out there that has gone through
anything and you feel like you just just
wait a second
just wait a second and be in control of
those moments because it means
everything in terms of this journey and
your life experiences and what I feel
like I was called to do
now I'm the hot vegan 72 years old you
can't mess with me now I know now that's
I mean that's Undisputed but
um
I think that Journey has a lot to do
with cultivating
self-love like you were a victim of
horrible situations and I think it's
very common and and uh you know to be
expected that those experiences foment a
sense of of shame or a sense of
worthlessness that make it very
difficult to hold yourself in in high
regard so where does that instinct
within you to Revere yourself so deeply
come from is that the result of a
spiritual practice is that something
that you just have always had within you
like how do you how do you uh you know
sort of embody that sensibility of
self-love such that because you can't
give love and be of service if you're
not thank you in healthy self-regard of
yourself so true you know
um
I I I think
as as a child I think it was always
there
but because I was so frightened I was
scared a lot I was scared a lot that I
was always going to be in trouble that
something was was going to happen to me
and then as I grew and because I was
raped I was raped once had to have an
abortion so when people have the
conversation about abortions I'm like I
paid eighty dollars for an abortion some
woman came into my my home and gave me a
a dish with uh
something really weird I think she went
to jail after that but it was like
really weird so if anybody ever offers
you anything like this the women say no
thank you but it was Ivory liquid
and pine salt
oh my God and I paid her 83 to do that
later on I think she did go to jail for
really hurting somebody
but um
I don't know I I walked into
this church
um City of Angels and the person that
was the speaker or the minister of that
church
was OC Smith God didn't make little
green apples you remember him OC Smith I
know but I know agape and yeah well I
was there too I was there within at
Agape and um
OC just spoke
to everyone I don't care if you had if
you were a pre a professor sitting in
that audience or somebody with like my
mom a third grade education
he spoke to everyone and I knew right
then and there I'm home it was all about
love it was all about now it was not
living in yesterday because he used to
say
yesterday is a canceled check and
tomorrow is an IOU all you have is the
moment what do you choose to do with
your moment
and I just started Living that I got a
teary eye and I have a nap here please
somebody will get you one but it was it
was that that started resonating with me
I have the moment I am in complete and
total control over my seconds and now
thank you sweetheart now I can be as
happy as I choose to be
and that is where I stay empowering
to have agency oh my God it's wonderful
it really and true now that's not to say
I don't shed a tear because honey I've
shared some tears enough tears to drown
um but I always I know where to go now
to bring it back to reel it in to say
this is your time yeah this is nobody
else's moment but yours what are you
gonna think how you gonna feel you're
going to laugh you're gonna cry what are
you gonna do with this moment this now
when I see people I hugged you as soon
as I saw you
I believe in the Oneness of the universe
I'm just I'm just somewhere else now
believe that we all were created by the
same intelligence and that we're one in
this I don't care about complexions I
think diversities are
we need to be embracing each and every
one of our differences
and learning to love one another and
that is what has gotten me through and
that is why I don't wallow in yesterday
and I really too worried about how I'm
gonna pay the rent tomorrow
because I got now yeah
intellectually I'm a hundred percent
there but in practice this is something
that I struggle with like I woke up this
morning
Melancholy and thinking about things I
could have done better the other day or
a stone that's unturned that I should
have turned over or a choice that I've
made that wasn't you know kind of in
alignment with the person that I want to
be and I'll beat myself up and I'll run
a tape and I'll loop on it and then I'll
be up and I'll wake up in the middle of
the night and think about it even though
I know everything that you just said is
true
making that leap from
understanding to practice to actually
living it in the moment to moment is
challenging right and you've seemed to
have mastered that I have my moments I
have my moments just like you I'm not
running a hundred
I just remind myself at 72 years old
sweetheart I figured within the next 20
between now and 28 years
that's what I have that's the time I
have
and I don't want to be as miserable
as I was hmm
so I remind myself even if somebody
hurts my feelings
I'll either either have a gentle
conversation with them this is how you
made me feel let's move past this
or or I just let it go I take
responsibility for it period yeah I am
you
are totally responsible for you
and I'm responsible for me and my
feelings and that's the good news and
the bad news it but but it but it is
what it is
and we've been given the power that is a
beautiful thing Rich to have the power
to determine what your moments are going
to feel like
that's power
I take and accept that power
so you have this realization how old
were you when this kind of came into
your awareness I was probably
uh man this life has gone so quickly
it's not probably around in my late 30s
yeah you know something like that and
during that period of time you had all
these different careers you worked for
the the airlines but you were you were a
hairdresser right and you were a singer
and then you were like singing in Tokyo
and like there's all kinds I mean like
there's so many layers like the chef
thing is like the most recent thing yes
you did a lot of things the floor
Arrangements that was a balloon designer
I did balloon designer I did all kinds
of stuff oh you know what but isn't that
the beauty of the journey and especially
a little girl coming from the east side
of L.A that we had nothing
to be able to say life is still good
I want to see what more it has to offer
and I'm just going to do me I decided
not to go to college so I didn't have
that but you know what I was
I had a lot of gifts yeah I was singing
and that's how you end up meeting Ron
right
how do you know all this stuff pretty
much I have not even had a conversation
with you it's a little bit of homework
try to understand who I'm going to be
sitting across from I should say because
I was going to say it at the outset like
you're here because I was at the mercy
for Animals Gala benefit and they gave
you an award and they showed this video
and you got up and you accepted this
award and you gave this impassioned
speech and I just I didn't know who you
were and I was like I don't know who
that person is but like I need to know
more about her I need some of that
energy in my life like I'm getting her
on the show you know come hell or high
one I learned everything that is so
adorable I love it okay what did you
just ask me how did you know about it
through your you initially met him
through didn't you audition well
actually
um he had a friend that um I was still
eating fish I was at the fish market
buying some dinner I had um
I had just gotten rid of all the men in
my world and so
um
yeah I did I used I used to be a hair
stylist I so I I had a um like a little
Salon created on my service porch and um
I went to the fish market and I met this
guy Ron's friend and they had a band
and so they invited me over I said yeah
well I'm a singer they invited me over
to come and audition and I did and
that's how I met Rondo Davis and he
actually prepared my very first vegan
meal for me and it was amazing because
food that was another thing that was
hard on me I had eczema
asthma
I was a Wipeout couldn't couldn't digest
my food because I just ate the standard
American diet and was killing me
um and he he prepared this beautiful
vegan meal for me and he um offered me
those two books and um I thought he was
kind of cute you know so okay I'm gonna
read the books I'm not really that big
of a reader but I'll read these books
best thing that ever happened to me hmm
yeah so Fit for Life and the mucusless
diet healing system okay I've heard a
Fit for Life I haven't heard of the that
other book though yeah but Professor
Arnold Eric it's all about reducing
inflammation that's essentially and
that's what he believed Arnold arid
believed I don't care what name you give
a disease you're pretty much just
inflamed sure so all of this are chronic
lifestyle diseases that we're suffering
from yeah whether it's obesity heart
disease Etc you know can be tracked to
the level of inflammation right that we
have and that inflammation as a result
of the foods that we're eating and the
lifestyle that we're living exactly so
prior to that though paint the picture
of your relationship with food and
exercise you know as a as a person the
pre I guess we're talking about the
pre-run well you know I was um when I
was a kid in high school I was really
fast I could always run really fast a
great Sprinter
um but when I got my first job I just
kind of sat down like everybody else I
stopped moving and when I met him it it
it has to be wrong when I met him our
first date was going up running the
hills at Griffith Park well he ran the
whole thing backwards and I kept
thinking to myself
something is wrong with this man right
and I couldn't understand but I don't
know if I like him that much I don't
know if I like him that much really how
many more inclines and he would say oh
just another one around the corner but I
thought to myself because he was only
two years older than me and I thought
wow
if he can run this whole thing backwards
I'm struggling walking
one of these days I'm gonna be able to
run this hill
yeah and the food part so what was your
diet like growing up
free free
Ron's first meal honey give me a pig I
ate everything from the rooted to the
tuna I actually ate chitterlings I
actually cooked chitlins I cooked
chitlins I saw the poop and chitlins and
still boiled them and ate them so you
know I just I I ate what you do but the
Recon sugar
very hard on me
um I could hardly wear anything backless
now you can hardly keep me out of
something backless
um like I said my skin was just ripped
especially after I got I and every
single month I broke out in my face like
with a rash that's crazy because your
skin is absolutely isn't that incredible
isn't that incredible no sense isn't it
it and and it was all diet related it
was all diet related unbelievable I
finally learned started uh treating
myself to massages and scrubs and I was
like
72 and you got skin they feel like this
so it was just a brand new world that
just I entered into with healthy eating
I could eat and I wasn't making the
loudest belches on the planet and I
wasn't
constipated constantly
um it just everything just got easier
and then with the movement I got
stronger
so now I feel worse if I'm not moving
than I do
keeping it going yeah yeah it's it's not
dissimilar from my own story which also
started at 40 changing my relationship
to food finding a plant-based diet and
then having that Resurgence of Vitality
and energy that got me interested in
movement and fitness for the first time
in a long time and those two things kind
of you know overlapping each other is a
very powerful really combination it
really is and I heard about your story
too and I thought about man he was doing
that thing around the same I mean you
know the same age as myself yeah I think
at 40 you know that's a moment where you
start to reflect a little bit I'm like
on the right path here you know you're
maybe you're a little more open to some
changes than you would other otherwise
um and it was a Line in the Sand kind of
thing for me just like it sounds like it
was for you like you all right so you go
on this hike with [__] he's running
backwards he prepares this meal he gives
you these books you read these books the
light bulb goes off and you kind of like
basically just cross that line in the
sand and that was it just like putting
the crack pipe down exactly yeah exactly
and and and now in terms of the whole
because it's it's not always been that
I've just been so
um
it's been it's very important to be now
to take responsibility for myself and my
feelings no matter no matter what I I I
take responsibility for those things in
particular
but it wasn't always like that I did a
lot of finger pointing and if it wasn't
for you and if it hadn't been for that
and if I would you know what I'm saying
the victim the victim and um it's it it
doesn't really serve me
in my life
to to be the victim I don't need to hold
grudges so how did you make that switch
just understanding and and and that's
happening right today Rich that it's
been a gradual thing for me to
understand
um because I can cry like that it does
it's not always coming from out there
why are you really crying
why is this really hurting you you know
um so I take responsibility for me and I
just think it's important for each and
every one of us to do that and to
understand that
they're all learning experiences I I
just appreciate this human Journey so
very much because from whence I came to
where I am now and my voice being bigger
and bigger I would have never thought
anybody would ever even listen to me but
to now share that Human Experience and
embrace love that is the key to all of
our issues
is love
it really is
I can't say it enough yeah it uh it's
certainly something we need a little bit
more of right now we need a whole bunch
more of it yeah
I feel like that relationship with love
and and connection with each other and
an appreciation of the wholeness uh
is a little bit fractured right now it's
very fractured but that's why we are
individually responsible
each of us you understand when each of
us takes on the responsibility
of embracing love
and understanding that there is no
separation
it's like
I am just an expression
of my creator
period it's like I can't make that
amazing mac and cheese I met made today
before I left the restaurant
without it being also an expression of
me yeah and so I know that I believe I
was created in and of this power of love
and so I feel better in that space than
I do anywhere else I feel like I've
known you forever I don't my mother
never met strangers and I remember that
as a kid I was like this lady talks to
everybody
is wrong with her she never met a
stranger people loved her wherever she
went I'm her now I just
I just want to embrace you I just want
to love you I'm not thinking about
anything else
I don't
I don't want to yeah it's it's it's a
beautiful Act of service also to uh to
embody that natural disposition but also
as somebody who makes food to prepare
food with that love and then give it to
somebody else like that is you know
there's a there's there's something
beautiful so beautiful about that right
you really know like obviously I get the
sense that all the food you make is
injected with your you know very
specific vibration of love like it's a
transmission of energy
there's a sacredness to that and when I
have my moments I'm human when I have
those moments when I'm somebody has said
something to me in the restaurant a
Rondo said something to me in the
restaurant and
um I have to remember the energy
I have to remember
me touching this food and I'm handling
food
calm down
let's go outside oh my gosh is it a
practice oh we've been in our screaming
matches before because we're it's real
I'm not trying to paint a picture to you
that that comes off like I'm Gandhi yeah
yeah I guess that no but there's there's
uh but awareness is what I have now
awareness and appreciation of the innate
fallibility of The Human Condition yeah
you know yes yes and to you know make
space for Grace with that yes right
I feel like most people want to eat
better they want to improve their diets
absolutely have you heard of it I've
heard of it this trips up so many people
we thought hey we know a couple things
about how to do this a few so we created
this thing called the plant power meal
planner that is this beautiful offering
whereby you gain access to literally
thousands of plant-based recipes that
you can totally customize based upon
your preferences your allergies your
peccadillos it integrates with grocery
delivery so all the ingredients that you
need get shipped right to your door so
you can make the stuff that you've
pre-selected and we all could use a
little inspiration and support when
preparing meals for our families in our
busy lives so we hope you join us no
matter what your eating style is we have
our arms open wide and we've saved you a
space at our family table to join us in
eating more healthy vibrant plant-based
meals and if you're looking for the
perfect holiday gift for a loved one
right now for a limited time we're
offering twenty dollars off meal planner
gift cards through December 15th visit
meals.richroll.com to claim the offer
again for twenty dollars off meal
planner gift cards from now until
December 15th visit meals Dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
so you have this kind of Awakening
moment
and you're embracing the Vitality of the
foods that you're eating and learning to
prepare but when does the
light bulb moment of like I'm going to
now take what I'm learning about food
and make it an offering for other people
you know Ron and I um we we dated for
two years and so I met him in 1919. and
we got married in 1992.
and our our lifestyle was pretty cool
you know we injected movement in that
and we've got a healthy diet we're
feeling good and I'm thinking this food
is really good
um
maybe we should share this so after I
went to Japan I thought I was going to
be a singer but when I was over there I
was cooking for everybody and working
out and I was like you know my thing is
really really movement and food right
now that's where I am so when I got back
to the States I decided I'm gonna I'm
gonna maybe have myself uh what do you
call those uh a company where I I can
prepare food for people if they're
having parties catering catering that's
what I thought I was going to do
and um Ron eventually asked me would you
like for me to help you in this and I
said sure why not
so we had an opportunity to go over to
Agape Spiritual Center
and uh Reverend Michael Beckwith allowed
us to bring our cart that we had built
on the parking lot and we began to
accumulate block long lines what years
was this this was like okay
um
late 90s early 2000s I don't even know
rich I don't know man it's 20 22. I'm
trying to think were you there I was
yeah no my wife and I would go to Agape
I mean we we
on Slauson in Culver in Culver City yeah
yeah
um maybe 90 2000 2002 three around that
era we we went pretty frequently and we
would eat so I'm pretty sure
I'm sure you ate my food it had to be
the early 2000s too because we were on
the parking lot for six years and
um
we okay
2004 we got the building on Market
Street we had no money it was a gift in
Inglewood
um the owner just almost gifted us the
place
and I remember it was 2004 it took us
four years to open the doors because we
had to get in there and try to fix
everything up right and um so yeah I was
I was on the parking lot at Agape for
six years so it had to be the beginning
you know yeah yeah early 2000 pretty
sure yeah yeah it was great the tacos
were really pop they were wild rice
tacos long line and they were pretty
popular and I had this souped up as like
a souped up top uh hot dog cart
um and we had a griddle Refrigeration we
could make smoothies on the other side
it was just awesome and we'd set up
every Sunday and
um yeah it was great and then we wound
up opening the rest of the doors in
2008. we didn't even have table and
chairs I think we had the three Bistro
tables and chairs we didn't even have
trash cans but we opened the doors
because I heard
that if you open the doors the people
will come and sure enough but that's
when mercy of our animals gave us our
they they really put us on the map yeah
they really did did uh business go
through the roof let me tell you when
they did that first video of me the
first one
um yeah it was the first time we ever
had lines like that we couldn't even
keep up
we couldn't even keep up it was
incredible the the the food cart at
Agape in the parking lot is almost like
perfect training wheels to figure out
like how do you make a business out of
this what are the recipes people like so
that by the time you're in the
restaurant you kind of have an
understanding of what to do we had
already basically
people had already tested the food we
knew it would sell we knew people liked
it you know
um and the only other thing that we
added because we were in Inglewood it
was predominantly black and brown
community at the time
um we
hadn't brought the soul food platter
into it so it was still just tacos
burritos the enchilada pie that had to
be the only plant-based restaurant it
was it wasn't anywhere on our side on
our side of the street it was a desert
there was not too much going on downtown
Inglewood in 2008. yeah but um yeah we
um
we added people would come in and you
know no chicken no no meat what is this
and um I would treat them to Tacos
because come back try my taco but I had
to put the soul food platter on the menu
yeah it was it was vital but you were
chasing people down the street you were
running out and giving them free food
come back in here and let me give you a
taco yeah how much free food did you
give away I might have given away a
whole bunch of free food but but guess
what some of those people became they
became perfect customers and I still
have some of those customers today yeah
you know well what's interesting is
first of all you you make the decision
to to open the restaurant in 2008 which
is the peak of the recession yes when
you decide to open up organic
plant-based you know Cuisine place in a
in a food desert uh and offer it to a
demographic of people who who you know
aren't inclined to you know be favorable
to that was that just who did that no
but like I want to understand like how
and and now you've made it work like I
want to you know you've got through the
pandemic I want to talk about that but
you know when we talk about healthy
eating plant-based or not like how are
we
educating people about how to take care
of themselves amidst a health uh you
know Health Care crisis in which
increasingly you know more and more
people are succumbing and falling prey
to these chronic lifestyle ailments that
are entirely avoidable through making
different choices and also ailments that
are disproportionately impacting
communities of color and and lower
income you know neighborhoods so on some
level like do you feel
you know this this this this calling uh
or a sense of responsibility to try to
do something about this or was this
merely an expression of your passion and
a way to create a business around it
like how do you think about those
broader issues about Health Nutrition
diet disease and and uh you know and how
it impacts your community it was all
about
um
a responsibility
it was more than just uh creating a
business for myself because trust me
I did not have to put a salad on every
plate
and we were the two my husband and I
were the two people that would come by
your plate and be like the only life on
your plate is that salad why are you not
eating do you need it to go container
for that salad you need to eat that
salad even if it's customers who were
willing to at least come in and pay now
you're gonna scare them but but what I
started learning
um through studying The China Study just
you know just increasing my knowledge
about my lifestyle if you will and what
I'm sharing with the message now we
created
a um
I like to say that our menu is one that
helps you transition it's a transitional
menu
um I have a lot of belief in eating food
lives I know that that is the best food
for me to grab hold too because I know
that every time I'm cooking something to
certain temperatures I'm killing the
life in that food
let food be thy medicine and Medicine be
thy food so I would explain to people
I'd put a salad on your plate so you
have some life on your plate this menu
is a transitional menu but
it'll take you away
from clogged arteries and some of the
horrible diseases we're faced with today
and I would always I would I would
always sit down with people and talk to
them not brow beat them except for the
salad but but just share with them like
I would always make this example
you love chicken I love chicken too I
didn't quit eating chicken because I
didn't like it
but check this out
if you burned yourself and it blistered
what's in the blister and they would say
puss or body fluids and I'd say okay so
you take that piece of chicken you stick
it in the oven
you pull it out and you open it up what
is that stuff oozing out of that chicken
and they'd go
they've taught you
that that stuff easing out of that
chicken is juice
it's body fluids
it you subjected it to temperature high
temperatures you've cooked it and now
it's that stuff is oozing out but you
would never prick that burn you never
think about pricking that burn and
sucking those Deuces no you wouldn't I
would do that people come in and all
that speech goes they tell me they tell
me that story a lot of them have
transitions because of that yeah because
I don't think we think enough about what
we're eating what we're really eating
what we're really ingesting we don't
give enough thought to it I used to
think everything sold in the supermarket
because of all of our governmental
agencies they're supposed to have our
back I used to think everything if it's
not if it's sold in the supermarket it's
okay to eat I really thought that way do
you know how many of us think that way
most people or if they think about it at
all think about it at all thank you very
much so
they survived those lessons from Chef B
okay
that's hilarious
um how has it like impacted the the sort
of community more broadly though like
the Inglewood Community like I you know
like
so much of it is an entry point right
but then they're going to go home and
they're going to do what they're going
to do and you know health care is about
follow-up care too and I would consider
you to be a healthcare practitioner in
the in the the truest sense of the word
um but really changing people's habits
in a sustainable way is as much about
education and follow-up and
accountability and creating kind of a
you know a
a community you know Bond over a certain
value that takes root
you know more of that is happening now
that I'm older
um
because
of who I am today
um
people believe me
I think they believe
they believe me more than they did when
I was younger you know
um they don't understand how can you do
75 push-ups at 72. why are you still
running that hill at 72 years why do you
still look like that at 72.
it was self-love and self-care
and now um I have people coming in
saying you know you taught me about such
and such a long time ago when you guys
first opened so now I hear more of that
you know
um but the beauty is that the change on
the planet right now I just came from
Saint Martin and they had vegan so you
know what I'm saying they understand
vegan
um so because of uh documentaries like
some of the ones that we've seen that
got people kind of fired up
um it's made my job and my place in the
community community more welcomed and um
it just has made my job easier if you
will well I think what you're doing is I
would argue you know more important than
the average person who maybe is your age
or eats well or even has a restaurant in
that
because of the fact that that you know
these these chronic ailments are
disproportionately impacting communities
of color you need role models and people
to look up to who are you know living a
certain lifestyle as Educators and
inspirers because
the vegan movement or plant-based or
whatever is is is often characterized as
an aspirational kind of high net worth
lifestyle that you know isn't accessible
to most people right and how can you do
it on a budget how can we make it more
accessible and affordable especially in
food desert communities where all they
have is a bodega and a fast food
restaurant on the corner they don't even
have a supermarket with the healthy
options amongst the unhealthy options at
the same time and that is really like
we're not going to solve this problem
unless we solve that problem which I
think is the biggest problem and the
communities that need the most education
assistance help
Etc you're absolutely right about that
and I um I would have to agree with you
I do
um Ron and I made the decision because
and that's why we named the place stuff
I.E
um we're pretty much organic
um uh that cost us a grip of money right
but um raise the prices you know what
I'm saying in a restaurant we brought it
to a community where they could have
cared less about organic
but that was one of our teaching points
if you try to get organic if you can but
if you cannot
try to stay plant-based
um
but it it wasn't and isn't
that simple
but
doing what we've done
we've been a gift I'd say to the
community because when they couldn't go
anywhere else they knew we were there
and then they would bring parents in
that are not feeling good can you do can
you suggest to us or my child has a lot
of dye I heard you had asthma what did
you do for that and that's when the the
gifting begins educating sharing where
I've come from what I've been through
what Rondell has been through with all
of those who care to know and
um it was a it was a very important
purpose
for Stuff I Eat to be there and to be
there then and now
um and thank God we made it through
covet yeah I mean how did you how did
you do that when it closed so many
restaurants uh we wound up
um just opening up
what was it Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday four days a week we sit down
and for um just take away and
um we had to let go yeah quite a few
employees so we're still down very
limited on employees
um we're just coming back we're still
not a hundred percent you know
um but
um we're not going anywhere either yeah
as a matter of fact we're now
contemplating
um a stuff I need to express
more of a franchise situation uh
probably won't have the soul food
platter in there but the easier you know
because like I said I make my own
Burgers everybody loves a good burger
uh but they're clean Burgers I you know
I just said and and that's another thing
we don't
feed people out of boxes and you know I
like fresh food
everything kind of comes from
plants and nuts and seeds and it works
that way except for like uh I just I
just beefed up my Mac and Cheese because
I kind of want stuff I eat to be known
for some
serious mac and cheese like Grandma's
mac and cheese but vegan so I've done
that but with like a cashew sauce yeah
actually
um we're using just one of the non-dairy
milks uh water and um some of the vegan
cheese to do that but I'm putting more
cheese on it and so it's coming off like
the traditional mac and cheese instead
of just this creamy out of the box mac
and cheese I got you oh yeah but as a
transition food as an entry point you
can if you can deliver on that yes you
got a customer who you know you can
pivot or kind of push them towards the
Cell 100 is so true but you know they're
eating their salads now okay I don't
doubt it I mean listen it's one thing to
profess a healthy lifestyle or give
somebody the science or have them write
a book but I think
what really
um impacts people the most is when they
see somebody who is a living example of
a certain lifestyle and they're doing it
in a way that is is aspirational but
still like you know not so far out there
that they can't see themselves in that
person and I feel like you
serve that role beautifully in many
categories I mean first of all somebody
who's been eating you know an organic
plant-based diet and I don't know
probably predominantly raw for like 30
years right now you're you're on the
cusp of turning 72 you're like I said
earlier you're just you're radiating
positivity your skin is insane like you
I mean I I it's it's crazy that you're
72 like you just you look like I don't
know you look like you're 36 or
something and you're totally jacked you
got like veins coming out of your arm
you can do push-ups all day and on
Instagram you're sharing these videos of
you doing your exercise routine and it's
very inspiring and it's very empowering
like reframing how we think about aging
and having this conversation around
longevity and the relationship between
the choices that we make the things we
put in our body the the choices we make
about how we interact with other people
like it's more than just oh here's a
salad it's about that self-love piece
it's about exuding love it's about like
how are you being of service how are you
contributing all of these things that
you're about without being preachy
you're just an example and they say
like in the parlance of recovery you
can't transmit something you haven't got
in other words you can't be you can't be
an example of something if you're not
actually living it yourself or you
haven't like intuited all of those
habits and you so clearly do that in a
beautiful way and I think that's the
real power in your message yes of course
the restaurant and all of that but you
now have this platform where you can
talk about these things and I think it
really
um
you know I know for myself even it
really helps you rethink about what our
relationship is to getting older and
what that means
it's a beauty of it the beauty of the
aging process
and after that's this entire Journey
to be able to say that I'm 72 and enjoy
each and every moment
of um
my time on this planet in this form
um
it's just amazing and I'm so grateful to
life I really am I'm so grateful to have
this opportunity to do what it is that I
do and love it so much
um wow you said a mouthful let's let's
walk me through the fitness routine I
want to know first of all you don't
sleep I I we can talk about that like
I've read that you get up at like 2 30
in the morning I don't know about that I
go to bed at six okay if I go to bed at
six come on all right they left that
part out I get plenty of rest trust I'm
very very still and quiet at home most
of the time I'm I'm to myself I live
alone I enjoy that
um
but yeah I usually wake up between 1 30
and 2. and usually I just get up because
then you know I'm I'm getting myself
ready if I'm gonna go work out with shop
Nam or
um go to the restaurant that day I just
get my day started early
um like you said the energy my energy is
just off the roof so I'm you know ready
to go but um to be able to um
to be able to share that and let people
know that man part of part of the whole
self-loving thing is to be a part of all
of this to be able to move you know if
if if I want to run a shield I can run a
hill I don't want to have a Life Alert I
don't I don't want to get in the bathtub
and can't get out so I force myself to
take baths sometimes I'm not always
taking showers make sure you get your
butt out the tub uh
but that's the whole thing when you get
older it's all about like if you fall
down and you can't and you can't get
that's that's what people need to really
understand now of course sometimes we
have accidents that you know is not any
fault of our own but uh well we just sit
down and just let it go that's generally
what will happen to you lose strength
and another thing that I I think
is I'm not a superficial person I am I
enjoy the aging process I don't look
like I looked when I was 60. you know
what I mean but
however it is however this look is going
to be as I age I embrace it because just
think I had lived an entire lifetime
looking different so you know what I
mean it's not a bad thing to have the
the crow's feet I I don't I don't care
to use anything to get rid of that I'm
okay with it I want to see what it's
going to be I saw one of the most
beautiful women I've ever seen before
she weared lines like in this table but
she was beautiful
she was beautiful and if just too she
owned it and she she's comfortable yeah
oh she was just gorgeous and that is how
we should all be because it's each step
of the journey that we embrace
and appreciate and don't you know I
can't I can't wear that I can't wear the
bushy eyelashes it's gonna be a little
bit too over that that don't work on
this face
but you did when you turned 70 you
posted these you did like a bathing suit
bananas like when everybody was sharing
that and it went crazy that one went
that was another like inflection point
in your your your kind of story arc
right yeah people really really love
that I got a little bold the next year
and did bikinis and stuff but this year
I am gonna do uh a beautiful
um
um photo of myself but um you'll see it
it'll be but no more bathing suit so I'm
good for that I still have my little
calendars I wasn't able to give them all
away and now it's the end of the year
you made like a bathing suit calendar
and yes I should have brought you one
hang it up over here oh man we got to
get you one you gotta get you one yeah
so I I still want to go through like the
day in the life the 2 30 wake up the
what is the routine I know you go to the
restaurant quite early but like walk me
through a day in the life of like food
Fitness being a chef especially if I'm
working that day and working out that
day so I get up around two
um take care of myself pull out my um
paint gun and
spray paint the face once I got her all
beat up and wrapped my hair then I'm out
of but but I I am I do have this to
admit I got a little OCD so
everything has to be exactly right in
the house I can't stand hair in the
bathroom uh-huh that's goofy but but I
once everything is exactly the way I
want it to be so when I come home I come
home to what I left then I head over to
the restaurant and I prep generally from
like four in the morning until we open
wow I do all the cooking right now and
sometimes I think I just you need to
find yourself a chef I'm too old for
this but
that's a hard I'm in a restaurant man
that's Relentless it's work sweetheart
you don't have Sous chefs and no no no
no no no no no I the one Chef that I had
there uh she's working in Arizona now
she had to move I loved her she was
awesome but she's gone and then covet
hit so we let everybody go so it's me
now coming back now it's me you know
coming back after this goes up I'm gonna
get some new people over there and I
know and then you know had the bank
account a little bit there you go hire
some help but yeah right at the moment
I'm responsible as a matter of fact I
was working before I came here today I
worked all day yesterday because I had
been out of town for a while traveling
and um so yeah I I worked all day
yesterday and went in there and they
still had a list for me this morning so
I completed the list came over here and
uh the rest of the day is mine I think
we have a zoom call today but typically
are you in you know when you're not
doing podcasts you're you're in the
restaurant all day and then you I'm in
the restaurant usually till noon
um and then uh if if my trainer can
um see me after I'm out of the
restaurant I'll go over there get about
an hour workout on with her uh stop stop
by rainbow Acres get all my goodies and
then go back to the house and um enjoy
Babette for the rest of the evening I
live a very simple life
um I'm careful about the energy that
comes into my space
because of my what I've been through I
understand I'm very very careful and now
I pay attention to signs whereas as as a
kid
you know something would be presented to
me and I'd be like isn't that that big a
deal I can handle that no no I pay
attention to the Signs Now
um because I'm responsible for me so how
do you work through what you say yes to
and what you say no to well um if if it
doesn't if it doesn't feel right
um
I'm real big on not hurting I don't I
don't want to create pain for anybody I
don't like messy I don't want to be
involved in anything where it's going to
be messy and somebody's going to wind up
getting I don't I know I don't want I'm
not into hurting that's not what I'm
about and if I hurt you let me know
because I am the first to humbly
apologize to you that is not my purpose
here to inflict pain so
um at my age I take control I take
control of me and then if I'm not in the
restaurant maybe a trainer has has time
for me at eight o'clock in the morning I
hit it right over there to my trainer we
get a cool workout on and the rest of
the day is mine most of the times I'm
busy on zooms or you know doing
something nowadays but uh I have a very
very simple beautiful
life right now yeah yeah
um but the fitness routine that's
basically like strength training that's
everything you're in the gym
and some hiking or stairs you like to do
the stairs and stuff like that but it's
pretty big I had a torn growing so I
hadn't been really doing too much of the
hype because
um I'm a part of a docu-series in
Houston Texas and um
yeah so we were we I was feeling good
from the grad I didn't feel like I still
had the tear
and we went to the track we got to the
track sister was sprinting and I was
like yeah I feel really good so I got up
there and and all the athletes
um were like no no Chef you haven't
stretched you haven't I got out there
and I
by the time I got to the end I had to
limp back yeah you know how grow on tear
will do it takes a long time a long time
yeah so we've been very careful my
trainer and I going forward not to
stretch that too much and I stairs I
love stairs and you know I love running
heels I just posted a video when we were
in Saint Martin of me hitting the hill
um I just love movement I love knowing
that I can move I love that I I I've
often thought if something ever happened
and I was the only person that could get
to help
even at my age I know I'm in shape
enough to do that right that's
maintaining that is so key especially as
you get older consistency yeah like the
the gym stuff becomes really important I
I I started with one push-up
and every day
I would add a push-up
and uh if I couldn't add a push-up I do
the numbers that I'd done the day before
but I tell people that I tell women that
start with one inch by inch Life's a
cinch yeah whether it's push-ups or
anything anything that's that's the way
you do anything yeah it's by starting
with one starting with one like I have
to do at least 72 push-ups on my
birthday
so I'm gonna do it in the restaurant
anybody that wants to come to the
restaurant and hang out and either get
down there and do some push-ups with me
maybe I'll give you a taco
this is why you can't hire somebody to
help you in the restaurant you're giving
away too much stuff that's my husband
you suck like
but but I figured like this if somebody
suggested to me because I was doing set
to 25 and someone said you know I I can
do that many but I do sets of ten and
then I thought that's a lot easier
because the the the time between sets is
only like a minute or two versus three
to four minutes when I'm doing set to
25. so I'm gonna do set to 10 I might
even get push out a hundred honey yeah
well if you break it down into sets of
ten then it's easier to build exactly
exactly yeah yeah so there you go
um yeah tell me about the docuser okay
check this out I I'm so this is another
thing that's so exciting I'm in two
Series right now how do you get to be 70
years old and then somebody invites you
to be a part in the series now the one
series is called the right turn series
I'm so excited I play myself pretty much
in that and that's probably coming out
towards the end of the year
um but then the the
um uh heart and soul of a champion is uh
Dr Baxter Montgomery who uh is a
board-certified cardiologist
and he's healing people through diet and
exercise literally he has a raw food
restaurant
in his practice so when his patients
come in and I mean patients with like
taking 15 16 different meds yeah number
levels all off the chart
and he puts them on a raw diet and guess
what they don't have to go home and cook
you just go to his kitchen and they'll
bag you up your meal and he has this in
his Medical Practice Medical practice we
were discussed in Houston right it's in
Houston we were just at
um a Gala event that he put on and
um very um beautiful doctors came to
speak we had John Sally there
um I love John yeah there was another
doctor there that I just fell in love
with I can't Ken Williams Oh I know oh
Kim Williams Kim Williams
incredible incredible but yeah former
president of the American Association of
cardiologists smart as can be and he
laid it out at that that um a Gala and
um just the fact that everybody that I
was responsible for interviewing our
guests as they came in
everybody's Story the same Rich healing
from food and movement healing really
really really chronic illnesses and
they're all like in tears because Dr
Baxter Montgomery
practicing medicine that's healing
people through diet it's just incredible
beautiful yeah and this docu-series
includes
um you got athletes you remember green
um what's his name um he was the fastest
runner
um yeah Sprinter yeah he he was run at
football football player NFL player yes
oh yeah he was there uh just several
different athletes and
the the docu-series shows you how they
came in
and how he got him within a few weeks
get their numbers down and all that kind
of stuff you know how it goes as soon as
you start the human body just starts to
heal if you're consistent and if you're
true isn't it incred isn't it such it's
just so intelligent it knows what to do
it does
yeah now look remember you gave me this
because my eye was tearing my body
always tells me when I've gotten I've
been a little out I went to Saint Martin
for some days and I came back and we had
to go to uh Houston and then I wound up
in Vegas you know that whole travel
thing
this eye gets inflamed if I'm
it's time to fast in other words now
once I fast and I'll probably do the
master cleanse because
um I'm gonna go hard on the cayenne
pepper and the lemon and and that sort
of thing within a week's time all this
tearing will subside been there done
that interesting and very interesting
very interesting you do that a couple
times a year oh I have to I I do it like
about I usually do three to four times a
year now Master Cleanse This Master
cleanses I'm going hard on this one
because I really need cayenne pepper
maple syrup and the lemon juice right
yeah yeah that's hardcore that one's
serious yeah but it works it really does
work as a matter of fact I can remember
the first time doing that and all of a
sudden after day four I could smell
everything I was like whoa I'm smelling
everything now it's it's an incredible
cleanse wow and incredible plans have
you ever played around with intermittent
fasting okay that's my thing that's how
so what does that look like for you I
don't even weigh myself I was still in
shop now I just make sure I keep that
separation between my thighs
you know what I'm saying yeah and I'm
good to go I'm good I don't need a scale
it's like no I'm still good here
where is the docu series gonna air
um I would have to
I think towards the end of the year I
think the First episodes are getting
ready to refer do you know where I don't
I don't have that information but we'll
definitely
Baxter Montgomery yeah brilliant
brilliant brilliant Houston it's
interesting that you know with all the
the documentaries what the health and
all that kind of thing and the the
explosion of interest in the plant-based
lifestyle and the number of plant-based
restaurants and food products and the
level of education has expanded I mean
it's CR you know compared to 2008 when
you open your restaurant and you know
that's kind of when I was starting yeah
it's a thing that it wasn't back then
but still people have difficulty
wrapping their head around
really getting on board even seeing you
at 72 banging out the push-ups and with
your skin and you know rocking the
attitude and like the whole thing
they're like yeah but like where am I
going to get my protein how's this going
to work like I I don't maybe maybe you
know but that is some crazy outlier and
it's not possible for me like so how do
you think about and communicate with
that person first of all we're all
animals we're part of the human species
we're all the same
period if it works for me
it will work for you
self-love self-care period educate
yourself because knowledge is power
don't walk around here being ignorant
and saying ignorant things and keeping
yourself
in an ignorant space
there's so much knowledge out here to be
to be gained all those documentaries
that you mentioned
do not often how many times I've watched
what the health and I always see
something that I missed
I just try to stay knowledgeable because
I know that this lifestyle this side of
the tracks has done me good so I want to
know more and more and more I can't
change anybody's mind
but I can be an example
and maybe somebody will change their
mind now
I don't know how quickly any of this
change is going to happen for the masses
we may not even be here
but I do know it's not just about the
one species on the planet is it about
the whole it's about our home it's like
you gotta at least understand that the
climate is changing because we're too
hot
so and that is primarily because of what
we're doing and our obsession with money
and power and greed
when the planet goes for me it goes for
you too you understand so I don't care
how much money you have and you can jet
off into outer space if you want to
but if you don't know how to take care
of this home you're not going to know
how to take care of that home either
so my thing is you better educate
yourself and you better understand where
protein comes from all the different
sources as a matter of fact here's the
old 72 year old telling you youngsters
out there Google it
I love that you're extreme like you're
just like I'm done with that I'm over
here now right like I that's the way I
function most people don't function that
way it will they're like I need a little
well I'm gonna try this and Dabble
around in this takes them a little bit
longer everybody's different and you as
a as an example or somebody who's trying
to like lead or hold somebody's hand you
have to be patient with that I could
still be crawling around on the force
smoking cornbread
the other thing though also is that you
know your entry point was your own
personal health as it was for me and now
you're talking about you know healing
the planet and our Collective
responsibility to you know shoulder you
know what we have to do to prevent
catastrophe that's you know uh uh that's
a realization that only comes in time
with this starting point okay and you
know look personal health you can
characterize that as sort of selfish
like I just care what I want to feel
like and Etc so somebody who says to you
yeah but I like my chicken or it's like
you know it's about my personal choice
and what I want right and then the
retort of course is listen you know the
the planet's burning we need to
understand like how we're manufacturing
our food and the downstream implications
of that on you know CO2 emissions and
all these other things that you know are
are part and parcel of the consumer
choices that we're making every day yeah
I I and and we we always responsible for
those choices even us in the restaurant
plastic plastic is over the top yeah
it's crazy and and it's hard to get
around that because it's very you want
to put a product out into the world or
your your vendors are sending you stuff
and everything is like and there's no
other way of doing it exactly like you
kind of have to figure out how to do
your best with a terrible situation
that's where you as the individual
you've got to take responsibility you
have to that is why that is why I'm not
crawling around looking for cocaine
rocks is because my mother if she didn't
teach me anything else
she taught me responsibility she did
teach me that and um
it used to be all about me
but I'm one with all of it so once I
began to understand my Oneness
with the whole
then it
it wasn't just all about me yeah you uh
that yeah part of that speech comes out
in your uh your brow beating of of
Howard Schultz and that Starbucks oh
yes but yeah so talk about that the
campaign uh to get because Starbucks up
charges for their plant-based milks but
they don't for their Dairy they give
away the creamer you can take as much
creamer as you want and and no extra
charge but you're gonna charge me for a
plant-based alternative I can't do dairy
I'm one of your customers that cannot do
dairy not just because I'm vegan
I can't do it lactose intolerant exactly
so you require me to pay more for the
plant-based option as wealthy as you are
give a little
give a little for the whole do that yeah
there's a you I'll put it's on YouTube
I'll link it up in the show now it's
nice has there been any movement there
any any response official responses you
know they just got in touch with me
today on doing something else with them
I was like Starbucks
that's it you know what I'm down
whatever we can do whatever I can say
what they gonna do to old lady yeah yeah
well you need me that's the good thing
about getting older is you start to just
not give a [__] you don't care anymore
you don't care no no because I know that
what I'm saying and what I'm offering is
truth and it's for the it's for the good
of all I'm not I'm not over there
putting out [__] I'm telling you the
truth through my experiences and I'm
sharing that with you listen or not
but but no no voicemail from Howard yet
not yet
um
I'm hoping maybe maybe I could get a
little you know but you know I haven't
heard anything there's an interesting on
this subject of of kind of expanding
your Consciousness you change your
relationship with food you're bringing a
different vibration into your body you
start to you know raise your you know
awareness of other things that maybe
you've been told earlier that aren't
quite correct and you start to question
some paradigms out there whether it's
the food pyramid or uh you know ideas
around what's good for you and what's
not good for you obviously that leads
you into an awareness of
of you know how we're treating all these
animals with how we're raising them for
food and it's not a big leap from That
Into You know kind of Justice more
broadly right so how do you think about
like your relationship with food and and
sort of the movement around that with
respect to you know the animal rights
issue and also just food Justice more
broadly
well in terms of especially with uh in
terms of the animal rights
um
we don't have the capacity
to
serve animals
and their byproducts
to the masses we we we're not we fit
we're failing at that we just don't have
the capacity
um when you think about animal waste
um and our water and our air and all of
those things when you think when you
make that connection you realize we
don't have the capacity we are we have
not we are we have failed
when it comes to
producing animals for food
we failed
um we're filling our health
individual health we're feeling the
health of our planet
we're killing off sentient beings that
want to have a life
that deserve to enjoy their
experience if you will
we kill elephants for Tusk are you
kidding me are you kidding me and so we
feel like we kill enough of them so if
we if they die off we got these tusks we
can say what is wrong with you
it's it's it's so
it's so selfish in the way that we
we think and live we're very very
selfish and we don't have a problem
hurting others to be that way
and it's for me it just um
it's painful to watch
but at the same time
as an individual I have to do my part
and speak my truth
um I hope that's answering part of your
of your yeah I mean certainly you know
we've we've created in this factory
farming industrial complex that we've
you know created a highly unsustainable
and and toxic industry that is you know
slaughtering and and torturing billions
of animals every year
if there's one thing that it does
successfully it it it it it creates a
situation in which that animal uses the
least amount of resources and is on the
planet as shortly as possible to blow it
up and turn it into food but the
byproducts the waste it's an intolerable
situation and it's just I think it's you
know toxic on a soul level too because
we've normalized it and we turn a blind
eye to it and we just say well this is
what we need to do to feed ourselves and
we all need to eat but I think there's
you know in the in the you know
background of our Consciousness we all
know that it's deeply wrong right and so
how does that kind of erode you know how
we feel about ourselves as a species I
guess right and if we can't
resolve that within ourselves how do we
then you know treat our brothers and
sisters with the highest respect and
regard you're right
and that right there
sounds like self-love to me if you don't
love you you can't live outside of you
and that's what I think is happening
because I love me so I'm gonna find out
what caused the eczema what caused the
asthma and I stay clear of those things
because now I don't want to hurt me the
individual by ingesting those things
that are going to cause me issues that's
practicing some self-love right there
but if you don't care to find out the
truth about what you should be ingesting
as a human
then that means you have very little
love for you
and so you shouldn't as heck are not
going to have
too much love for anybody else and
especially animal now you gonna love
that dog I'm gonna love that dog a cat
that dog and that cat better not touch
that dog or that cat but the hell with
the pig cow chicken
or turkey so it's like or fish
what are we doing we go out and we catch
all these fish and all we want is tuna
so what do we do with the rest of the
fish
you know what I'm saying so it's it's
it's us
individually
every each and every one of us has to
determine what is important to me about
The Gift of Life what is truly important
to me
and and being amongst I I went to
Yellowstone one year it was one of the
most beautiful places I've ever been in
my life and to see all of nature just
walking around doing them you know what
I mean not bothering anybody I went to
Kenya same thing just
just seeing nature
but then I can look at a documentary and
see chickens housed in
and warehouses and pigs and people in
the community being sick from the waste
and
each and every one of us has to change
that and and we have to demand change
but we have to know why we need to
change
and and that's
it's like lifting weights
especially
get those real heavy ones when you just
got to get stronger and stronger and
stronger Embrace work that has no ends I
love life and and I'm embracing the love
of life and all all life on this planet
so if somebody's listening to this and
they're like man I just I need some of
that energy in my life like I'm inspired
by what a bad house to share I I know
that I haven't been practicing self-love
and I haven't been taking care of myself
or I haven't been you know eating the
high vibration foods and I just don't
know how to start or where to begin like
how do you guide that person what's the
first
step to catalyze that trajectory well
first of all I I just share with them is
everything that you ate you just omit
this this and this that is why we have
the menu that we have tacos burritos
quesadillas you know what I'm saying
it's a it's one of those soul food I
make sweet potato pie I just don't use a
dozen eggs in it like my mama did you
know I figured out how arrowroot powder
works you know what I'm saying so I can
still have sweet potato pie I can still
have the mac and cheese so my share to
them is
you don't have to really omit anything
but death that's the only thing I'm
asking you to stop ingesting
um
and just they have so many vegan recipes
now I will go if I want to make
something because I'm not a self I'm a
trained Chef I'm you know come come out
the kitchen at home and took it to a
restaurant
but I can look up recipes I'll play with
them and make them my own that's all
that's it's that simple now for those in
who who live in areas and they can't get
out they you know like you said the food
deserts I I made a post one time I
wasn't trying to be funny
I I went to Vons which is a place right
by the restaurant and I went in with my
phone and I was in the produce section
and I said hey you guys you see all this
this is food this is real food I just
shot every oranges apples potatoes
everything and I said too much of this
is what we eat and I went over to the
Cracker section you just say the whole
rest of the market you could have said
that for sure but I went over to the
Cracker section and there was something
on a box of Cheez-Its that I had never
seen before because I don't buy this
product but I went to the ingredients
because too many times people are
looking at the nutritional facts and
they avoid the ingredients I don't
personally care to eat anything or
ingest anything if I can't I don't know
what it is but I don't know what the
word is I can't even say it I I don't
know if I should be eating that
um I kind of like words like apple
orange broccoli those words I got
and on the box of Cheez-Its it had
in very light black writing
that it was bioengineered
it's not even real
it's a food-like substance that they've
created in a laboratory now when I
started that video but then I had I got
feedback from a couple of people like
well you know some of us live in areas
where that's all we have
and you don't want to come off
insensitive and be like that's when we
need to get some planting pots
and go to Costco
or a a Home Depot and pick up they have
organic seeds now and sometimes we need
to start planting our own food if you're
living in the area where you can't get
too fresh food
sometimes you have to take the
responsibility of planting your own food
and feeding yourself
now but it's a lot I mean you know
that's a lot to ask especially people in
that Community are working multiple jobs
and and some of them don't you're asking
them like now I got to grow it myself
some of them are still where I was
thinking that everything they sell in
whatever supermarket is okay to eat
because the government gave the okay
and I I have to remember that as well I
was there I thought anything in the
supermarket was A-Okay right and there
are tons of people out there just like
me and living in food deserts who's the
guy I'm looking him up right now the the
guy in La Ron
um who's the Urban Gardener who's T
who's oh yeah you know what I'm talking
about what's his name I forgot his last
name Bennett uh I forgot his last one
has it been it because I know his
brother is uh Ron Finley Finley yeah no
run yeah like taking over vacant Lots
yeah what and what he did was he planted
uh right at his curbside he was planting
food and people could come by and pick
whatever they wanted that's how he got
started and the city tried to give him
Flack for that right you can't try to
shut him down you have to put grass out
here I should be giving him money today
to do it yeah and they try to shut him
down with that that's not still the case
though is it no I think he he started
massive Ted Talk he did okay right he
did okay after that we need more of that
we need much more of that but that's my
point
can government get out of the way and
allow us to nourish ourselves because
you're not you said it's okay to put
those crackers in the store
oh this is the best part of that
I got home my granddaughter was living
with me and she has a little
two-year-old
I looked on top of my refrigerator those
same Cheez-Its
for in my apartment
and she had been giving them to her
child the same ones and that is what I
mean it's it's we're so wrapped up in
ignorance not knowing and of course I
had to share that these crackers are in
my house and I just made a video about
these darn things but um yeah we just I
don't know sweetheart I don't have all
the answers I wish I did I share when I
can share and because I don't want to
come off as mean or cranky or I got it
all together because I don't
but um
educate yourself right well you're doing
your part you know I think what you're
doing is beautiful I think that you
um should have like your own cooking
show on network television like I you
know more Babette out there right and
like why you I know you have this cashew
book but you should have like a
full-blown cookbook you must be working
on that you know what Chef is I have a
another book that has been written for
at least two years it's called um stuff
your stuff
and what I've done is I've taken
portobello mushrooms
uh bell pepper
the huge tomatoes and uh potatoes
um
and uh I've made a different stuffing
for each one of those four like four
mushrooms four and they're absolutely
delicious all I need to do is just write
the book I have all the recipes
all down ready to go I just haven't
written the book If you get up at two in
the morning
sounds like you're busy though but I'm
sure you got to squeeze out time to I
need to get that book out I see that's
motivation thank you motivating me and I
think you know you need like some kind
of
fitness challenge that brings the
community in like I know you like hey on
my 72nd birthday I'm Gonna Do 72. Right
push push-ups but
um I think there's a lot of people out
there that you know are enjoying what
you have to offer and to make that
analog like something in Griffith Park
or something you know that's community
base where people could actually come
out and do the workouts with you you
know I've thought about it yeah you know
I have and and right now because I'm so
responsible for prepping all the food in
the restaurant and my time is how to get
you out you need infrastructure I do
honey because your your shit's going
like this it's scaling you know but you
got to figure out
um how to surround yourself with people
who can do the things that you can
delegate so that you can be you yeah
because the world I agree I love you for
that thank you yeah well let me know how
I can help out with that okay I will
anyway
um any last thoughts here before we wrap
this up well just um I want to thank you
so very much for having me on
um
I'ma tell you a little secret now
shopping I'm probably already blabbed
her mouth but shop said get in touch
with Rich Roll and I was like she's not
gonna even read my message come on
and uh and she said
try it just Reach Out
and when you responded to me
I reached out to you well what was funny
is I had been at the gala and I was like
oh I'm getting I'm getting her on and I
might have mentioned it to somebody or
whatever so I was like I was getting
ready to send you a message and then you
sent one to me like literally that day I
was gonna ping are you kidding me I
don't know so I thought maybe somebody
told you like oh rich wants to get in
touch no it was shabnam that my trainer
that that told me get in touch with him
and I said he's not going to read man do
you know how many people try to get in
touch with me and I don't even see she
said I bet you he will just try it and
when I reached out and I've never done a
backflip in my life oh I almost did one
after I said almost something right you
knew what I was doing or who I was
because I I had just seen you and I was
like this is great oh my but I just want
to say thank you for what you're doing
to your podcast is off the chain I love
it I always just I was so excited about
coming on because it just the way you
speak it just it felt so comfortable and
I knew I was going to have a good time
here but
for my brothers and sisters on the
planet
try it try embracing love starting with
yourself
and then don't worry about anything
other than the fact
that
you are an expression of the greatness
that created all of this
be the best expression you can possibly
be
beautifully put
anyway I think that's a good way to end
it yeah how do you feel we did it
wonderful I think we did pretty good we
did good yeah you feel good we friends
we we is family now I gotta get you out
of here before your bedtime too
you did not you did not say that
I go to bed at like 8 30 and I thought I
was a lunatic so
you got me beat
all right baby all right well come back
and talk to me again sometime all right
much love peace
[Music]